[Music]
major changes for the carolina panthers
after the 2019 season ron rivera out as
the head coach matt rule in cam newton
out is the quarterback teddy bridgewater
in luke keackley retires greg olson is
released
a lot of changes for a team that comes
in at number 30 in the state of the
franchise series because look chris you
throw in the pandemic new coach new
quarterback new everything yeah no
opportunity to get anyone on the same
page
off you go
with with a with a division that has the
saints and the buccaneers and the
falcons who were six and two down the
stretch last season yeah well i mean
this is a totally different looking team
i mean it's a totally different era now
in carolina now you know you bring up
they got a lot of moving parts you're
right this offseason screwed them over
in a big way the teddy bridgewater
though you know just as far as that's
concerned hey look i mean that's that's
the the the marquee move of the off
season right paying him he does know
this offense you know as far as joe
brady the offensive coordinator from lsu
who came up there to carolina he was in
new orleans so i'm sure there's going to
be a lot of carryover that helps him yes
but you know i do i'm interested to see
where this teddy bridgewater thing goes
i am you know you know dorado's career
been very conservative certainly i
always use the phrase you've heard me
say it where i just go you know he
doesn't lose games but he doesn't win
games either you know and that that'll
be the big thing for me to whether he
holds on to this job and truly
solidifies himself as a you know
starting nfl quarterback because i think
he teeters on that border of yeah it
could be a starter but it could be like
just an awesome awesome backup too i'm
not sure i'm sold either way yet but the
thing is that you got to be excited
about if you're teddy bridgewater or
carolina i mean
man they got some ballers on on their
offense they do i mean we know they got
the best running back in the game you
know dj moore is one of those guys that
i i was i it killed me that i didn't put
him on my top 10 wide receiver list you
get a dd uh uh not d wesson robbie
anderson from the new york jets
you know jj more car yet on twitter too
or was it just devante no i think just
devonte adams and dj moore though that
bothered me a lot it did it actually
bothered me not having him more than it
did devonte adams because you know more
more especially he's a weapon guy too
like a tyree kill or a debo samuel and
that's and that's fashion so a lot of
young guys that i think got a lot of
talent but i don't expect anything big
out of this football team this year at
least i don't know how you feel about it
joe brady running the offense he comes
from
new orleans by way of lsu
familiar with teddy bridgewater familiar
with the sean payton offense and look we
do see a lot of dinking and dunking from
teddy bridgewater he's never had big
numbers but last year when he got a
chance to run that sean payton offense
5-0 yeah with
weapons around him and it's been a long
road for teddy bridgewater and i am
rooting for him i hope he does well that
catastrophic knee injury in august of
2016 derailed what minnesota quietly
believed would be a breakout year and
here we are four years later where he
gets a chance to be a starter again with
his own team he's making more money over
the next three years than patrick
mahomes also by the way assuming that
the carolina panthers keep him for all
three years of the contract and if they
do that will mean it went very well but
what do you expect to see from teddy
bridgewater in this offense run by the
guy who who knows him from his time in
new orleans yeah you know i i expect
uh you know good numbers i'm not gonna
say superstar type play i hope he plays
a little bit more aggressively than he
has in years past you know and maybe
this is all emboldening him to have the
weapons around him and knowing the
offense and knowing all the different
options to where it makes him play that
way you know i do but you know again i
don't i'm not sitting here saying he's
got to like reinvent himself or totally
change i just wish he was a hair more
aggressive because i do i think they got
guys that can make big plays i mean they
got legitimate speed at receiver you
know dj moore robbie anderson curtis
sandville they'll run by just about any
corners in football you know a pretty
good tight end play and then we know
mccaffrey so i look at that and go yeah
but i'm equally as excited about some of
the things they got on the defensive
side of the ball too to me
i really think matt rule and company did
a phenomenal job of flipping this roster
and you know still giving themselves a
chance to be very competitive and you
know i i don't expect a 2 and 14 type
team i don't you know you know the first
pick of the draft they get derek brown
arguably the best player in the draft i
mean other than joe burrow for me you
can make that kind of argument he's a
difference maker all those young guys
they drafted on the defensive side of
the ball their whole draft was defense
you know i liked them all so uh it's a
team with great potential i just don't
know of course i don't think it's going
to get there this year
they got all their defensive draft picks
all of their draft picks under contract
yesterday so they are good to go no hold
out issues no problems like that derek
brown was one of the first first
rounders to sign earlier in the year but
you're right this is a work in progress
this is a reclamation project for matt
rule we saw him do it in temple we saw
him do it at baylor
and and it's going to take time and and
i think anything they do this year
that that would be even remotely close
to 500 that's cause for celebration
because it's all about laying the
foundation for 20 21 but at the same
time you've got christian mccaffrey in
his prime yeah right i mean at the same
time if you have an opportunity to reach
for the brass ring and if it falls your
way and if you get lucky and you win
some games early and you build some
confidence and guys by hand we talk
about that all the time the best thing
that can happen to a new coach is to win
games early because guys buy in they
believe they feel good about themselves
confidence begets more confidence and
you end up finding yourself in a spot
where all of a sudden you're contending
when you get into october november and
early december and and with that seventh
playoff spot that's the thing i think it
becomes harder
to write off any team
in either conference this year when you
throw an extra playoff spot into the mix
chris yeah yeah i i i mean i'm with you
there uh and you know i don't know if i
expect this team to be in that
conversation i don't you know
i i'm like we've talked about excited to
see some of these guys
but you know you kind of hit on it
already matt rule first first year head
coach you know
joe brady first time nfl offensive
coordinator not really that extensive of
a resume even in college and then the
defensive coordinator phil snow has
never coached defense in football in the
nfl either you know college football and
there's going to be an adjustment period
there like listen i know phil snow is a
hell of a coach you know but there's
going to be a part of him that's going
to learn to go you know he's going to
have his code cracked for the first time
this year where he's going to go oh wait
nobody in college used to do this to me
when i played this coverage and so
there's gonna be a lot and and now you
know brady and and sean payton have
found uh you know some some cracks in my
my schemes and i have to readjust how i
think and what i do on the defensive
side of the ball so to me let alone
grooming these young players
i i could almost see this being almost
like a miami type year that like we just
saw last year where they might start out
0-4-0 and five oh and six but then we
get to that second half of the year and
they're a pain in the butt for everybody
they play and maybe they rattle off
three four five wins at the end of the
year and you know you go into the end of
the season going whoa watch out for
carolina next year they might have
something brewing that's literally what
i'm expecting from carolina here in this
first year under matt rule
and when i think of all the
circumstances conspiring against the
panthers this year the lack of an
off-season program with the new coach
with the new coordinator right with the
new quarterback i
i think back
to the story from 2011
when jim schwartz then the coach of the
lions told the harbaugh brothers
especially jim who was first year with
the 49ers with no off-season program
basically you got no chance this year
yeah it did you got no chance and jim
sitting there seething
as jim schwartz told him you got no
chance you got no chance and then when
they got together in october and the
49ers beat the lions that was the
i went in too hard i i went in too hard
i went in too hard and aggressive that
was my fault
yeah yeah right your buddy jim harvey oh
yeah my good old buddy yeah right tell
your dad i said hi yeah go to ohio state
let's go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports